after my Sat Nav sent me on too busy
roads one time too many I'm finding my
way myself
not so easy without technology
taringa with all its hilt is nice enough
but it also true pain slowly I'm
reaching the border to Bavaria and the
former in a German body I've now arrived
at the border between the states of
thuringia and Bavaria I have just 35
days left to reach my destination since
the nineteen fifty the almost fourteen
hundred kilometer long border between
the federal republic of germany and the
GDR was right behind me separating the
Western democracy on the one side from
the communist dictatorship on the other
side here in the German German open-air
museum in the thuringian village of
bailing in the border installations have
been almost completely preserved and you
can see just how elaborately the former
East Germany sealed itself off the mayor
of Burlington knows the fortifications
well how was the border structured as
pecan we didn't film that made it began
with a 500-meter protective strip and
then offense with warning signals and
then came another 500 meters of guarded
straight and then a border fence with
the patrol road and ditches to keep
vehicles out some with automatic firing
mechanisms and some areas were mined
right up to the Bavarian border d4 means
one Wow
this deadly and impregnable border was
meant to keep people from fleeing he's
Germany dobson where their attempts to
flee right here the fruit to hook up see
you yes certainly several but nothing
really unusual happened near us there
were incidents in the next section of
the hoarder for instance a man stepped
on a mine while trying to get over the
fences and he was seriously wounded from
nineteen forty nine to nineteen ninety
germany was partitioned into West
Germany and East Germany on november
nine nineteen eighty nine the opening of
the wall enclosing west berlin which lay
in the middle of the east was hugely
significant military and border staff
were part of everyday life he and be at
home between the 1950s and 1980s as well
what was everyday life like for you here
today I perfectly normal we thought of
it as normal of course we were in an
exclusion zone so we had some
restrictions our relatives couldn't
visit spontaneously we had to apply for
permission I'm pass eh I've been thrown
ah getting permission to visit seems
pretty restrictive to me be odd how did
it feel not being able to go to the
other side I do i was born in nineteen
forty nine so it didn't make that much
of an impression for us children it was
normality we could only leave in one
direction during vacations but the
border didn't bother us personally at
all i want special huber help me custard
but that's not how every citizen of the
former East Germany saw it
luckily this is all in the past let's
see how well East and West Germans know
their neighbors on the other side of the
former Border 20 years after the
reunification which picture shows a
rappers housing in the West this woman
recognizes the neighboring village right
away so does this schoolboy this man
does to let cross over to Bavaria which
picture shows bailing in in the east
this woman immediately points to the
right one so does this woman and this
man they all recognize what was long
unreachable I'd say Germany is now
really reunited and off I go again
towards the south with a feeling of
satisfaction about German reunification
you